[Musique]
il a une buvette imite celle ci auger
chantal hébert bon choix bon sens a
besoin la question qu'on posait beaucoup
à 20 samedi soir dans les semaines qui
ont mené à l'élection de monsieur
poilievre c'était la division haut
potentiel dans ce parti est ce que les
lady progresser ça allait pouvoir reste
etc or ça a un peu changé compte tenu de
l'ampleur de la victoire mais je vous
entendre monsieur deltell ce matin qui
lui était dans le kent de monsieur
charest s'est dit en tout cas
officiellement rassuré parce qu'il a
entendu ce matin au caucus du québec
menée par monsieur poirier vont
l'écouter
ce matin nous tous les députés du québec
ont été leurs la peau retrouve bohm on
voit le chiffre et laquelle bon moment
l'oncle très bon signal envoyé par le
chef d'unité par le chef d'être à
l'écouté du québec je pense qu'il l'a
très bien démontré d'ailleurs lors de
son discours
hélène est ce que la question de l'unité
de ce parti là c'est régler d'après vous
je pense surtout qu'elle ne peut plus se
poser vous l'avez dit les chefs les
chiffres pardon son sont écrasants il
n'y avait pas d'opposition à nos cieux
croyez-vous à peu près pas si ce qui me
fait dire que c'est un chef
incontestable c'est à dire que oui il
est bel et bien le chef mais que
quiconque aurait des récriminations à
lui servir ou d'autres à son égard ne
peut plus vraiment les exprimer il ya
pas beaucoup d espace pour ça ce que les
résultats de samedi soir nous démontre
c'est que cette fameuse est elle appelée
la progression modérée du parti
conservateur elle est maintenant
totalement minoritaire dans ce parti
noël ne fait pas le poids et c'est ce
qui explique que les députés qui ne
m'aimait pas monsieur croyable sont
obligés de ravaler et de faire bonne
figure aujourd'hui je pense notamment à
joël godin est là qui nous avaient dit
qu'ils avaient à la presse moi ou bien
comme indépendant je quitte je
démissionne je rejoins le parti j'en
fais un autre et bien et tout d'un coup
nous dit que c'est le statu quo et qu'il
doit réfléchir on sent qu'il n'y a pas
d'espacé pour émettre un quelconque
couac dont michel c qu'en pensez vous
il n'y a pas d'espacé dans le caucus
conservateur pour contester un chef qui
a été élu avec 66% but d'escudé tenez
votre exprimer ça c'est certain est ce
que les électeurs suivront ça c'est une
autre question mais on pourra pas le
démontrer à l'altitude mais pour les
députés
le seul choix c'est de partir ou de
rester et c'est très rare qu'on voit des
députés après un congrès qui a qui
n'apportent ça arrive mais ça arrive
souvent surtout pas car le chef a été
élu avec ce genre de majorité nord et
que ses députés la dda leur compte et la
plupart du temps ont vu les balles ou de
leur compte et battait pour le sucre au
diable à des majorités substantielle je
crois qu'un seul d'exécuter ce monsieur
martel au saguenay qui a vu qu'il
donnait une majorité à monsieur charest
dans la danse on comptait alors à un
moment donné on peut tout le choix c'est
de partir ou de ce type si vous partez
vous n'êtes plus rien rester chantal
d'accord
c'est une question de l'apport de force
monsieur poilievre et son équipe ont
affronté la quasi totalité des députés
du québec et les hommes battus sur leur
propre terrain on parle même paul de
l'ensemble du québec mais de ces
circonscriptions qui était conservatrice
5 fois sur 6
il ya personne qui est incapable de dire
si tu m'as pas dans ton équipe ben je
vais entrer chez moi puis je vais garder
mes acquis puis tu vas en avoir besoin
ce qui était intéressant aujourd'hui
aussi c'est que le plan de marche
libéral c'était vraiment que de laisser
la poussière retomber parce qu'elle est
y avoir des divisions puis tout à coup
il se passe rien de ce genre il s'est
apprécié de nécessité pour les libéraux
de trouver une façon de cinq séries dans
la conversation parce qu'ils peuvent pas
se dire pendant la première semaine puis
à poitiers va perdre son temps à essayer
de garder son caucus c'est parce qu'il
est entraîneur ou je vais vous faire
entendre une déclaration que monsieur
poilievre et je voulais faire entendre
pour montrer que puis là nous en parliez
samedi soir que le québec peut devenir
important évidemment bien sûr l'ontario
c'est une évidence mais qu' il peut
avoir non pas un potentiel de croissance
au québec pour le parti conservateur du
canada est là cette déclaration du
samedi soir qui a fait jaser je voulais
présenter on revient tout de suite
je vais aller plus loin en parlant du
québec je dirais que les consommateurs
de partout au pays ont beaucoup
d'apprendre des québécois les québécois
défendre leur patrimoine leur culture et
leur langue il ne s'excuse plat la
version québécoise c'est en tête aux
rockies main
la nation québécoise qui tient tête au
hockey mais bon le la langue la culture
les québécois qui sont fiers et on a un
début sa femme qui est ici qui a été
élevé en trop dans l'est de montréal
plus tard d'hochelaga et voulu parler
aux gens dont chantal hébert est ce que
tu fais est calculé on la voit c'est la
fête de son bébé aujourd'hui on dirait
plutôt tous et calculée et on sent que
ce point lièvre il voit très présent au
québec qu
il va être très présent au québec parce
que il a personnellement ganil québec
dans une course au leadership ce que
personne avant lui prédire même stephen
harper il n'y a pas de producteurs
laitiers qui sont allés à la fin faire
la différence sur le 13e tour de scrutin
ça c'était maxime berreby comptable ou
scheer donc oui il va être très présent
au québec mais aussi il ya fait quelque
chose quand même il leur fallait passer
à côté de la déclaration sur le web
parce que on n'en sortira jamais si on
essaye de définir ce qui veut dire par
de france qui s'en vont avec ça ça passe
au dessus de la tête selon moi et avec
raison de la vaste majorité des
électeurs mais
ce qu'il a fait dans ce discours doit se
dire des choses que normalement un chef
conservateur vient 10 ou au québec pas
le soir de sa victoire quand tout le
monde dans le parti est en train de
regarder et je pourrais même michel va
s'en souvenir et stephen harper sa
première sortie après être devenu chef
c'était à la chambre de commerce de
laval on n'était pas nombreux pour dire
ce genre de choses là mais pas dans une
assemblée aussi large où il y autant de
l'histoire qui n'est pas du québec et ça
c était jusqu à un certain point non
seulement intéressant mais un
avertissement pour le bloc québécois
parce qu'ils aient pas seulement 10 buts
justin trudeau au québec qui vont être
en train d'évaluer tout ça est aussi
forcément le bloc québécois michel ces
prêts vous pouvez vous essayer sur le
web michel mais ça fait partie du disque
nos outils et sablé cheminots 6 2 deux
mesures au lièvre j'ai voulu envoyer un
message avec vous mais sur l'importance
du québec on l'a senti même si y'avait
pas de tant de français le français qui
avait été assez claire à michel
weedon pas chapelle dit
il l'a répété les mots qu'ils utilisent
a passé il a répété d'un guide a alors
saisi vos parties excusez moi mais ce
que j'ai dit sir compte pour vous aussi
ça ça veut dire des choses la deuxième
c'est que pour un député qui
devient chef et qui n'a pas été élevé au
québec comme le mâle rhône est chaud
c'est la première fois qu'on est chef
conservateur depuis très longtemps pour
qui le français pas une langue apprise
où il ya la main joueurs de rock est
capable quatre mots contient 10 nov si
ce n'est qu'ils vivent aujourd'hui alors
il peut parler aux québécois directement
sans être obligé de passer par un
lieutenant québécois où tout ça c'est
très important aussi on verra ce que ces
politiques pour avoir comme effet au
québec on verra quel est le lien qui
peut faire avec les résultats s'ils
seront des conservateurs québécois est
chaud mais y la ville avec une certaine
un certain bagage qui est différent des
autres et si envers le québec risque
d'être fort intéressant comme dynamique
quant au hockey ce qui gêne le team que
jusqu'à monsieur legault s'est excusé
d'avoir dit oui puis aujourd'hui
c'est parce que pour beaucoup hélène
donc bah oui mais moi ça me fait un peu
rire parce que je trouve que ça
ressemble un peu à leur cette
déclaration de monsieur poilievre
lorsqu'il dit et québécois défendre leur
identité ne s'en excuse pas qu'elle
serait peut-être les deux éléments en ce
moment sur lesquels les québécois
s'exprime le plus pas pour leur identité
on pourrait parler de la laïcité des
migrations or sur la question de la loi
21 monsieur poilievre dit très
régulièrement qu'il était contre cette
loi s'il était député à l'assemblée
nationale une voix très content il
n'attend dos répond une loi similaire au
niveau fédéral et au début il avait dit
bon on laissera les québécois mené une
poursuite judiciaire de l'homme les
tribunaux et un mois plus tard pendant
un débat il a reviré cédait 0,10 que non
ils
interviendraient au fédéral dans une
telle poursuite sur la question a fait
la même politique que monsieur trudeau
le la même exactement exactement et
c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs parce
que au départ monsieur poilievre se
retrouvait avec la position la plus
proche des québécois les québécois qui
au sein du caucus conservateur disait
faut pas se prononcer sur la loi 21
sinon ça va faire un ressac au québec et
c'est pour ça qu'on appuie monsieur
charest il était votre idée un peu les
culottes à faire parce que monsieur
charest admission différente est
finalement monsieur polyexpo lièvre
repris la même mais aussi l'immigration
aussi monsieur poirier avait totalement
d'accord avec les cibles d'immigration
fixé par monsieur trudeau qui
essentiellement les 12 par rapport à une
quinzaine d'années et même qui dit qu'il
veut favoriser l'immigration des
travailleurs spécialisés en accélérant
leur reconnaissance des titres de
compétences ce qui est de compétence
provinciale
alors il ya quand même des éléments
quand on vend dans le concret qui ne
sont pas du tout en phase avec le
discours identitaire
revendicateurs des québécois d'ailleurs
monsieur legault a dit je le connais pas
je vais le rencontrer ses cheveux vue
viva d'eads et des discussions
intéressant un mot sur monsieur trudeau
on va l'écouter tout de suite parce que
la partie vient de changer pour les
libéraux c'est clair on écoute monsieur
trudeau sommes midi à sainte anne jose
des slogans des phrases creuses les
attaques insouciante c'est pas ça avoir
un plan
les canadiens font face à toutes sortes
d'épreuves
parce que partout dans le monde on
traverse une période tumultueuse et
notre tâche en tant que gouvernement en
tant que leader c'est de bâtir sur ce
qu'on fait depuis 2015 et de prendre des
décisions parfois difficiles mais
toujours responsable est toujours dans
l'intérêt des canadiens
en deux mots il s'excuse pas d'avoir
beaucoup dépensé on l'a entendu plus tôt
et dit j'ai dépensé beaucoup mais
savez-vous je leur ferai tour de table
michel serrault j'ai d'abord ce que
c'est vrai d'après vos piles on l'a on a
beaucoup parlé de ça depuis qu'il a 10 à
son conseil des mines est ce que vous
croyez qu'il est encore plus
attirés par une autre bataille
électorale compte tenu de son adversaire
poilievre
michel
c'était sûr qu'ils mettraient en route
assure qu'
il dise tout ce moment dit alors ils
peuvent pas dit non j'ai peur de lui
alors attendons c'est une chose
deuxièmement
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont plus raisonner le
site rue d'authie attaque monsieur coué
bien sûr il a dit elle chausse ses
baskets chat ou cissé poilievre qu'ils y
ont joués occuper de votre portefeuille
votre chèque de paye de votre hypothèque
et du gouvernement qui dépense beaucoup
qui a créé une inflation ça c'est pas
dresser mondial mais en même temps c'est
une ligne d'attaqué qui risque de
fonctionner alors est-ce que critiquer
poilievre être suffisant s'ils
n'apportent et gantois lieu du 17 mai
pour capable de nuire et passeports les
problèmes affections aussi donc il faut
que trudeau arrivent avec des solutions
concrètes pas de s'attaquer pour chantal
oui je crois sur parole justin trudeau
quand il dit qu'il entend toutes choses
étant égales parce qu'on sait jamais
mené le parti pour une quatrième fois en
campagne électorale
ne serait ce que parce que
les moyens de payer
larbi autres et en même temps se
préparer pour cette campagne électorale
l'autre chose que j'ai noté dans les
propos du premier ministre qui me semble
plus important pour la suite des choses
que toutes les choses qui aurait à dire
sur les phrases fusent toujours un peu
étrange quand on entend justin trudeau
dire phrases comme important c'est de
faire rire et chanter
ouais ouais mais c'est
ok il ya toutes sortes d'expressions en
anglais
mais dos mais entendons-nous c'est sur
l'idée et cette ligne l'homme semble
plus porteuse que on vocaux combattre
l'inflation sur le dos de la lutte aux
changements climatiques
et là dessus je pense qu'il ya un filet
désert du côté du parti conservateur je
suis voilée en france qui peut s'en
tirer parce qu'on s'inquiète d'économies
que la donne a changé à cause de la
guerre
votre intervention précédente montre que
tous les avantages de l'inflation mais
aussi cette guerre pourrait ne pas être
au rendez vous de la prochaine campagne
mais les changements climatiques eux ils
vont y être espérons le pour la guerre
mais changement climatique se sentir au
pollen oui moi aussi je crois monsieur
trudeau qu'il veut à être de la partie à
la prochaine élection pour la raison
bien simple mois avant même le
couronnement de samedi le j'avais fait
plusieurs appels auprès de plusieurs
stratèges et hétéros qui me disaient
mais si c'était jean charest qui était
ce qui devenait chef peut-être qu'il
serait temps texan dans l'est parce que
bon il se sentirait pas d'être plus
menacé par un chef centriste qui
viendrait peut-être volé de l'électorat
libéral mais il est menacé parce que
charest ferait du pile comme il avait
créé ou en fait que oui c'est ça fait
que monsieur charest pourrait pâtir
gagné donc ce sera peut-être plus
avantageux pour lui de tirer sa
révérence alors que me disait ton envers
monsieur poilievre on pense avoir une
chance et m'a surtout dit sûr de pouvoir
vraiment le démolir je sais pas si c'est
vrai mais c'est ce qu'il pense ils
voient ça comme une guerre philosophie
quand son héritage et une autre sorte de
patients mais tenable semble tout cela
chaque vision et c'est pour ça que je le
crois je ne pense que c'est simplement
de la bravade je pense vraiment qu au
fond de lui ça dit chercher très bien
mais en même temps ces cinq héros
propositions vraiment différent il nous
reste sept minutes
immigration on va écouter monsieur
legault bon le décès de la reine a fait
que on a moins parlé de tout ça jeudi
vendredi samedi mais là on en reparle
sur la campagne québécoise on écoute
monsieur legault revient
je le répète c'est une richesse mais on
a un défi de prendre un nombre
d'immigrants qu'on est capable
d'intégrer pour protéger long terme de
france lille france est en déclin
actuellement au québec donc cohésion
nationale au québec les gens sont autour
de certaines valeurs sont une nation
c'est serré mais pour qu'une cohésion
nationale focal nation une nation forte
que la nation québécoise pour être fort
il faut protéger le français
bon hélène c'est quand questionner
monsieur legault sur sa déclaration
d'hier sur la cause est ce que
l'immigration n'est pas une menace à la
cohésion nationale
là il n'était plus dans sa déclaration
de la semaine dernière qu'il a dit
regretter c'est à dire que le lien entre
immigration et la violent mais là on a
on parle beaucoup d'immigration
peut-être plus que jamais dans cette
campagne avec des cibles différentes
mais encore une fois iode des
philosophies différentes derrière oui en
fait ça me fera commencé un peu le débat
sur les accommodements raisonnables qui
revient à l'avant-scène à l'avancé mais
avec des mots un peu différent des mises
en contexte différentes mais
essentiellement c'est toujours cette
même idée cette idée que on doit
préserver une certaine façon d'être
collective à laquelle on invite les gens
à se joindre mais à y adhérer et non pas
à transformer cette façon aux entrepôts
de transformer de manière significative
ou fondamental cette façon collective
d'être et ça peut être un peu maladroit
monsieur lebon n'est pas très habile
dans le maniement de ces de ces concepts
un peu délicat il était carrément planté
sur la question de la violence la
semaine dernière lui été sauvé par la
reine il faut quand même le dire mais je
pense que si on est pour faire une
analyse ses électeurs vont me pardonner
parce que ils comprennent ce qu'il veut
me dire et je pense qu'un grand nombre
sont rarement d'accord aussi oui chantal
et michel conclusion chatah bon la
première fois sur un accident la
deuxième fois c'est un appel du pied
d'accord avec elle est menée comprenne
ce qu'il veut dire est ce qui veut dire
c'est que vous avez raison de vous
inquiéter de l'arrivée des migrants
parce que la diversité ça change la
cohésion de la nation québécoise parce
que
c'est un message qui promet des
lendemains qui chantent pour la société
québécoise où la diversité va
s'installer toute façon pas
nécessairement mais de toute évidence
entre les deux il ya dû y avoir des
sondages internes qui montre que même si
monsieur legault a dit j'aurais pas dû
parler de ça c'est des licols des
questions de valeurs entre les deux il
doit y avoir des sondages qui suggère
que c'est peut-être d'ellicom et ces
pays michel
effectivement subi deux cas et c'est
payant en même temps et à chacun que je
le vaux arrive là dessus on le sent mal
à l'aise dans le sac
le problème c'est le message qu'il
envoie la diversité pause les garantir
si une cohésion nationale qui est
assurée par le français qu est ce qu on
dit aux immigrés qui sont arrivés ici et
qu'ils ont appelée français on leur dit
ben quand même
c'est ce qui est fatiguant dans
le discours de monsieur leroux c'est
ainsi c'est nous contre tout le temps et
même si vous avez appelé le
transmettre on va peut-être à cause de
voir ce problème d'unité nationale et
à la fin ça crée des sacrés du division
c'est pourquoi merci beaucoup à vous
trois bonnes soirées à très bientôt pour
voir ses romans